[Music]
No thank you no that's very nice you've
been vegetarian for 40 more years right
Tom yeah and not just one day a week but
24/7 yeah
how has that affected your life it's I
love it you know and I get mates you
know and people say don't you miss your
sausages and stuff I don't do you don't
know this there's so much good return
for these days anyway that you've got
more than enough my original thing which
still is at the core of why they say was
compassion I just saw a video of the
campaign oh yeah
and what I one of the things I think is
so interesting about it is you're just
asking for one day a week mmm
why did you decide to just do one day a
week I think you know if you say to
people I'm a vegetarian I think it's
great I've been this way for 40 years
now you should be a vegetarian it's too
much for them to take in what it means
they've got to change the whole
lifestyle so what we find is if you say
to people we'll try one day they can do
that and they're kind of willing to do
that and then some people go oh this is
good well maybe I'll do two days so I
think you think's like that yeah I don't
think you're gonna approach with the
sledgehammer you've got to kind of just
keep it gentle venom
well sometimes you know I see
environmentalists with messages and it
sounds like moralistic scolding and I
don't know that it's terribly effective
I try and keep it as something that I
would have understood and I would have
accepted before I was vegetarian
so years ago we were linden I were on a
farm and we had sheep and they'd had
lambs and it's the most beautiful time
of the Lambs life they're sort of full
of spirit and full of energy and we
happened to be eating like a lamp
we weren't vegetarian and so when we
made the connection we said you know or
should we try and not do this
so we did and never look back but it
basically was sort of out of compassion
for these lambs who just been born yeah
we're in the first month of their lives
and were shortly to have ended it's like
doesn't seem right but they're more
recently people have started to draw
this comparison between greenhouse gases
and just basically too much livestock on
earth it won't be so bad it was just one
or two on a farm but well there's
billions the way we now do it it has a
big effect on the atmosphere and there
was in 2006 there was a report that came
out from the United Nations called
livestock's long shadow that I read it
explained that that livestock were
responsible for more greenhouse gases
than transport which I thought it was
airplanes trucks cars I thought that was
the big culprit but when they when this
fact came out I thought well you know
that's important it's quite quite
amazing and you don't think about it but
then when you start to think wait a
minute some of the fast food people
their prevalence in the world and the
amount of cattle needed to feed that
worldwide craving is huge so do you
think that there will be receptivity to
this message I mean a lot of people
don't have any problem with eating meat
they just think what we do that's how we
grew up yeah well I was that yeah and
that's exactly how I was still in my
case I saw the lemons and made the
connection I mean like I say you know
for me the bottom line is we are on this
incredible planet and there doesn't
appear to be another one within sight
somehow it seems that we are this
miraculous little planet and we are on
it this human race and alongside us
these little dudes these animals and
that we've all got this chance in life
to sort of survive and so I like the
idea of giving them their best shot so
you know that's the idea for me is just
it's a life and I don't see why I
shouldn't allow that animal to have that
life when I don't need to take it I mean
I like I used to do a bit of fishing I
remember catching a fish once and all in
him in and just seeing him kind of
struggling for life but I thought oh
okay you know that's where you live
under the water now I'm pulling you out
into this alien that was fierce so what
did you do put him back but that was the
last time I fished because I you know
I'm I suppose I'm a bit conscious of
that now particularly whereas when I
grow up you never thought of it as meat
it was just some stuff that arrived from
a supermarket right and didn't look like
an animal until my mom one day served
tongue which looked like oh no it's very
good you know it's but generally
speaking you didn't make that connection
because he all came right so I think
that's you know how most people are I
think there's a tension a little bit
sometimes though between we're able to
say we're not gonna eat meat a day a
week or not eat meat at all yeah you
know in a lot of parts of the world
though there are people for whom raising
livestock is their livelihood and that
in parts of the world even having one
pig or one goat or one cow is sort of
the road out of poverty does how does
how does you how do you balance this but
I don't think that's the problem
I think the mass production is where the
big problem starts to come in where
certain companies have billions of
animals not just one Pig billions of
pigs
often cramped in a little in a really
cruel condition so all that comes into
play and you know I say to people that
what happens is like me I was brought up
just ordinary people in Liverpool and we
just had ordinary food just same as
everyone in our streets but when I
reached certain age I made a change I
just thought you know maybe this isn't
what I want to do I've got the free will
to do something else so I encourage
people I say it's it's actually quite
fun when you look at what you do what
you eat how you live and think is this
I'm going to do it the rest of my life
or would it be kind of interesting just
to try making a change and I think a lot
of people do that these days
particularly I just think I think for a
lot of people they think vegetarian oh
that means I have to eat tofu all the
time yeah you know and that doesn't seem
appealing to a lot of people no well I
agree with that
the truth is there's a lot of options
these days so that what we're doing with
meat free Monday is just urging people
to just try it one day and because it
will make some kind of a difference if
enough people do it or if the idea
spreads you know every every week I'm
hearing about all my kids has just
decided he wants to go over to tear
because he's a sports man and you know
it's decided that's better for him was
it hard to get other people to join this
message in that video I saw you've got
Emma Stone and woody harrelson I mean
are you still recruiting other people to
try to take this message forward as I
say I know a lot of people who are
either veg town woody for instance Woody
Harrelson is very vegan I mean you look
he's a strapping lad you know and he
does all sorts of action pictures of
he's very healthy and Emmas a friend and
I like the idea that people will like
the fact that she's a great actress and
if she says the message you'll just get
a bit more attention you know I meet a
lot of people say well you know I still
eat me but I'm too
you know eating less and people that we
call their meat producers Mira do okay
step there are people who do that yeah I
might sort of ultimate theory is that
you've got this beautiful little planet
we've talked about and it's going to be
overpopulated is it doesn't seem to be
anywhere around that so you've got to
make the food go further and it helped
by not passing it through a cow so you
think some of the some of the main
advantages here are personal health
I mean tells of the planet animal
compassion mmm what am i leaving out
those are the three okay over those I'm
sure there are other reasons but I think
those my main three so you're one of the
most famous people in the world you've
been one of the most famous people in
the world for a very long time you could
support so many causes and have your
voice heard by a lot of people why this
cause and why now well this is personal
you know this this is person and I do a
lot of other causes too but this
particular one this is how I live and I
like the idea of this particular
campaign because I can then say to
people just try it if you were me what
would you ask yeah what do we think
about National Geographic
I love gnashed Geographic and I've loved
it since I was a kid it's sort of always
there that yellow frame and you know
exactly where it is and you know you're
gonna get great photos and great stories
about the world so it brings the world
to you and so say I've always loved it
anyway but one particular issue in the I
saw in the 60s had a woman and she
looked very proud and she had a baby and
I saw that as a kind of Madonna thing
mother and child and I could just you
know sometimes you see pick
she said mothers you go she's a good
mother if you just tell there's a pond
and and I it just affected me that photo
and so I was inspired to write lady
Madonna my song from that photo well you
know I I hear that from people all the
time how they would open the magazine
and get a sense of the world that
otherwise they never had because you
know you know lots of us didn't grow up
traveling around the globe as kids and
so we got to see everything that's right
I think that was one of the great things
about it
well great photography well and great
photographer who well Paul I just want
to thank you so much for talking to us
about your campaign and sharing your
your feelings about it well thank you
very much I'm honored to be in ng thank
you thanks a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you